t
la colère. Volodomyr Zelensky
ne s'est pas remis de ce
qu'il a vu à Boutcha la veille.
Pointant du doigt les troupesrl
de sécurité, les atrocités,
les massacres dont il a été
"Ils les ont mutilés, égorgés,
di
violées devant leurs enfants.
Mais il n'y a pas que Boutcha,
ajoute-t-il, il y a Irpin
et plusieurs autres villes
♪ ♪♪♪
Et pour appuyer ses propos,
avec des images insoutenables.
♪ ♪ ♪
Puis, se tournant
vers le Conseil de sécurité...
"Êtes-vous prêts à fermer
NaNaNaNations unies?, lance-t-i.
Les lois internationales
sont-elles dépassées? Si vous
répondez non, alors il faut agir
immédiatement, affirme-t-il.
Les Nations unies doivent être
réformés, le droit de véto,
sa propre enquête.
ssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssss
ces images à Boutcha,
affirme le secrétaire général
Antonio Guterres.
Il faut une imputabili
"Tout ceci est une vaste mise
en scananananance l'ambassadeur
russe aux Nations unies.
Aucun civil n'a été tué
russes."
"Nous n'agissons pas comme  S ,
dit-il, qui ont rasé des villes
entières sans pitié. Nous avons
qui est proche de nous."
Le ministre des Affaires
étrangères russe,
Sergueï Lavmamamamamamamamamamao
a pour but de faire dérailler
gogogogogociations entre Kiev
et Moscou.
Toujours est-il que plusieurs
enqu e e e e e en cours,
dont celle de l'organisation
Human Rights Watch.
et Asie pour Human Rights Watch
- C'est que e e e e e doit être
impartiale parce qu'une enquête
dont l'intégrité est en doute,
d'une enquête comme ça.
- El
l'organisation enquête
égr r r r r r des violations du
coté des troupes ukrainiennes.
qui montre comment les soldats,
les soldats ukrainiens, ont tiré
sur les jambes des prisonniers
de guerre russes.
"Nous sommes témoins de
la plus grande menace à la paix
et à la sécurité en Europe
et dans le monde,
42 ans de carrière militaire."
Pour Washington, il n'y a aucun
doute : le p p p p p p p p p p e
internationale pour crimes
de gue
"Les États-Unis ne sont pas
membres de la Cour
ancien ambassadeur américain
iéiéiéiéiéiéiéiétique, et donc e
permettent pas à ces citoyens
d'être jugés. C'est hypocrite
d'autres pays devraient
le faire."
En attendant, la Russie fait
face à de nouvelles sanctions
européenne a déjà annoncé
qu'elle allait cesser toute
importation de charbon russe,
qui constitue 45 %sososososososr
d'autres sanctions économiquess.
Ici Azeb Wolde-Giorghis,
Radio-Canada, Washing